IGNORE IT, LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT HUMILIATES JOE BIDEN.
UKRAINE IS NOW DEMANDING MORE
MONEY THAN ITS ENTIRE PREWAR
BUDGET --
WILL GRANT THAT REQUEST BECAUSE
SECURITY -- THEIR TOP PRIORITY.
SHOWING THAT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER -- CONGRESSMAN
ANDY BIGGS, WHO REPRESENTS
ARIZONA --
>> AFTER THIS --
THEY ARE GOING TO WAIT HOURS.
THERE'S LOTS GOING ON HERE.
>> SO, WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
"HER.
PROBABLY A LOT OF REASONS READ
THE OTHER NATIONS DECLARED THAT
THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER IS THE
DEADLIEST IN THE WORLD.
MULTIPLE TEXAS COUNTIES DECLARED
TODAY THAT WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
AN INVASION.
ANDY BIGGS REPRESENTS ARIZONA
AND JOSH CONGRESS -- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS FROM TEXAS
CALLED THIS AN INVASION.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S FAIR?
>> IT IS ACCURATE.
ARIZONA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL --
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING FROM THE
VIDEOS, TUCKER, THAT'S A REGULAR
ROUTINE.
PEOPLE FROM GEORGIA, ALL KINDS
OF LATIN AMERICAN COUNTRIES,
AFRICAN NATIONS, CHINA, INDIA.
THAT HAPPENS EVERY MORNING.
THAT WAS ABOUT 4:00-4:30 IN THE
MORNING THAT DAY.
IT'S NOT STOPPABLE, BECAUSE WE
BASICALLY SAID COME IN AND THEY
SAID " --
THAT IS AN INVASION.
>> SO THIS WILL COMPLETELY
CHANGE AMERICA.
IN A DEMOCRACY, CITIZENS GET TO
DECIDE THE KIND OF COUNTRY THEY
WANTED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THIS
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME COUNTRY.
WHY IS THIS NOT A CRIME THAT'S
BEING PROSECUTED?
>> I THINK IT SHOULD BE.
THEY HAVE DELIBERATELY,
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS, THEY HAVE
DELIBERATELY STOPPED ENFORCEMENT
UNDER TITLE EIGHT WHICH IS THE
IMMIGRATION -- AND
ADMINISTRATION ACT.
ALSO, TITLE 42 WHICH THEY ARE
HEDGING ON.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING ICE TO
REMOVE PEOPLE, AND -- THIS
AMNESTY PROGRAM TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
TO ME, THAT'S A VIOLATION OF THE
LAW AND IS DANGEROUS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT TERRORISTS,
CRIME, THE DANGER TO PEOPLE
COMING IN ILLEGALLY.
SPEAK ABOUT THE GUY INVITING